[Music]
does it seem like construction is
happening everywhere you turn well the
city is proposing another project this
time further down Rancho between 95
South to Santa Fe Station Madison
Kimbrough joins us live in that area
tonight with the latest Madison
yeah the city plans on hosting two
meetings both of which are open to the
public this week to talk about this
possible project now take a look here as
it's going to start on Rancho Drive this
possible project and then go all the way
down to Rainbow Boulevard which is over
a six and a half mile stretch
down here they need more lighting for
sure it is pretty dark the city has its
eyes on a potential new Street project
with a focus on Rancho specifically from
Mesquite to Rainbow Boulevard
the city's goal create a street design
that is safer and more attractive for
motorist pedestrians and bicyclists I
don't think we often give our like bike
riders enough space other proposed
improvements include three lanes in each
Direction offset sidewalks and a shared
bus and bike lane
councilman Cedric Creer of Ward 5 hoping
that by having these public meetings
locals will speak up and share with the
city what they feel needs to be done
more Orleans is needed since the since
the population is growing I think they
need more sidewalks more more stop signs
because there's a lot of people that
don't know how to drive in general if
this project is given the green light
the city will use federal funding to
implement changes and according to the
city Rancho Drive is ranked to the
fourth most congested non-freeway in Las
Vegas drivers over there on the freeway
they just cut people off just just like
nothing but no signals and not warning
people you know it causes a lot of
accidents the freeways they never used
to be so packed
we will have details on when and where
the sitting meeting will take place this
week up on our website it's going to be
attached to this story at 8newsnow.com
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now